iran's foreign minister says he came to
lebanon to convey the islamic republic's
support at a time of economic turmoil
but hussein amir abdullahian also
asserted iran's influence it has been
sending shipments of fuel to help with
shortages in defiance of u.s sanctions
we will stand by lebanon with all our
power in order to break the tyrannous
siege that lebanon is going through at
such a critical time in its history
iran's ally hezbollah managed to bring
in iranian fuel through u.s sanctioned
syria a few weeks ago it used it as a
political tool and declared victory the
move wasn't approved by lebanon's
government prime minister najib said it
violated the country's sovereignty
nevertheless he received the iranian
diplomat
in fact the lebanese
state is
completely
is completely left
powerless
in face of this breach of the lebanon
sovereignty but more importantly mr
miati and his government are here
in order to
to find a way to get lebanon out of this
economic and financial crisis
lebanon is an economic turmoil it's
seeking a bailout package from the
international community this could
undermine iran's influence since the
much-needed hard currency will have to
come from the west and lebanon's
traditional allies gulf arab countries
as of late those governments shunned
lebanon because of iran's influence here
as it is caught in the middle of
tehran's rivalry with saudi arabia and
the united states
hezbollah is armed and along with its
allies controls political power in
lebanon critics say it is furthering
iran's agenda at lebanon's expense
we don't feel that lebanon is besieged
by
by by any country
the only country that is severing or
making lebanon severe really in the de
facto its relations with the
international community is the
malpractice of iran and its proxies here
the visit by iran's foreign minister was
more of a message than one of substance
and while he received a warm welcome
lebanese officials were careful at least
publicly not to position themselves
firmly in one camp senator al-jazeera
beirut